she's too busy taking pictures welcome
everyone
the Monday mayor very excited this week
we have four MMA fighter and current
entertainer whoa Brendan Schaub with us
from the fighter in the kid podcast
you've seen him everywhere he's you've
got live shows coming up live - yeah
tours were in Texas New Orleans East
Coast New York all over everywhere and
all over the goddamn Internet welcome
everyone today we're gonna play one of
my favorite games of all time Gears of
War it's my - man what I grew up on this
it's a classic we grew up I warn you my
daycare was intend to 64 I was tight so
my dad put in the Nintendo 64 and that's
what we did should we do hardcore do we
dare you know we're gonna let's do cash
let's do casual for right now
everybody's going on a pit christopoulos
Kayne Twitty good to see you mom what's
up y'all bad twerk what's going on
everybody
oh we got in the middle of Brendan
Schaub I just introduced him no let's
start it we're starting a new camper -
Brendan we're just talking a little bit
before we got started how did you
transition how did you get from the
Octagon to podcasting cuz it doesn't
seem like it doesn't make sense it
doesn't make any sense
it's like a zebra hangout with lions
you'd be the light it's like a lion
hanging with soup really I think it's
calling a bunch of podcasters lions is
very it depends very pastors are to
shake it and you do the podcast at Bryan
Callen Bryan Callen right now from the
hangovers in the city all those movies
that's right I ride along but he's his
number one passions being a comic that's
also man I fell into this I was doing I
was fighting doing the podcast with
Bryan and he just took kind of took off
and then literally before my last fight
things that fine kid were going so well
I'm walking out the rock I'm like you
know what question and then forced me to
wear Reebok pumps house like you know I
don't like
I would rent you how to rather get punch
the base all right so I think you are I
hear I am on the top
okay I'm bottom here your bottom yeah
let the top alright so I don't actually
remember that how to play this game at
all so we're gonna figure it out
together let's see here so here we go
there we go yep I get the trigger we're
good yeah so really it just kind of took
off and then I loved doing I enjoyed
doing it and yeah Fox and then Ben's
milky soup Brian the 60 year old kid
he's 50 that's it he's very dear you
exact we're just gonna go straight into
combat training last rainy come on three
amateurs yeah exactly
yeah big rounds on the bottom what's
your other what you also the hybrid is
that your size oh cool so I get the
nickname the hybrid from The Ultimate
Fighter is that could you drive a Prius
all the time you know I did drive it P
is super depressing got rid of that
thing finally oh my god what oh that's
you know I got rid of that thing
definitely set my game up that I'll get
in and just kick it get in that's why I
think maybe you don't see it in horror
movies cause horror movies are like
trying to start the car door is just
like there's no sound yeah this is not
that dramatic yeah they're so dangerous
to they this shoot it's like a cardboard
box or that trick it's okay it's like an
electric root everything up is Leonardo
DiCaprio tries when someone's like oh
they're cool and they got them we up
from my three eight shops the man Brown
that's right what up guys it's the Prius
to start it always kick it always kick
it no wait what are we what am i said
what are we supposed to do somebody
jumped out so you kill them something
yeah exactly I just want - I want waves
of enemies to just destroy all right
this is all garbage you know what man I
I'm so thankful that we're playing Gears
of War because I love this game and I
still grew up on this game about GM I
thought you're in fortunately played the
UFC fighting game oh no oh no no I would
never know the meathead stuff matters
we were say you a tech bubble technical
balls funnel ball NBA Jam no I made Jam
supply I feel bad for kids cuz when I
was a kid going to the the arcade was
like Disneyland man oh yeah play Tekken
all that stuff
oh this guy's having a bad day oh this
is the fridge all right I love other
just trying to set the scene for us like
dude we just want to kill things
dude I'm 12 I don't care about the story
you don't want my favorite things about
Gears of War is all the guns have
chainsaws on them also like that is
pretty high here we go here we go
today's games are so real I know oh I'm
dead I'm already dead I'm already dead I
literally said sup [ __ ] I said I got I
can recover you that I died do they
still have arcades yes a little on the
old fairy tale yeah sorry go thank my
boy alright I got this shoot it's always
red jelly coming off him okay wait a
second I gotta help you out I gotta help
you up you might want to kill him before
alright right through the pain that's
all it took by the way you're just like
thinking about all right how do we jump
over this okay right I think it's oh
that's the green button so you hit it
once to go behind it then another you
know the games today are a little too
real for me yeah I know that's the thing
it's real I'm trying to relax have fun
man I'm not trying to well we weren't
you know we were gonna actually play
this game Tom Clancy's the division
okay so clients again stressed me out I
know but it's real for me it's a little
too real then it's like look it's like
we had to sign up for like 15 different
accounts and then man you have to be
online in a whole two hours loses in
exactly it's like have some fun I know I
just want to start a game and play it um
so tell me about the fire in the kick
yeah so you guys have been doing uh been
doing it for about four years we've been
with Fox for two now that's awesome yeah
but we were doing a Brian's garage and
we're in life beaters and just having
fun man and then what I'm seeing Colin
what's one of the things that like early
on because you know you not coming from
a podcast background like what was one
of the things you learned early on about
doing a podcast that I could be myself
oh yeah
chosen when you do the the UFC
interviews and the fight interviews yeah
it's all like I'm gonna beat this guy up
training so tough is the same thing no
one really learns who the real guy is
doesn't it it does because it is still
kind of like entertainment it's in Lane
and you are kind of playing a character
a STONER Doug w/e but because you can't
joke around and anyone knows me like my
family friends I'm a silly guy right all
the time when you tell me I had to be
serious it doesn't go over well right
really not that tough really not so oh
the podcast is like oh I can I can be
funny and being Brian Collins partner
he's a comic so dude it gives me a
pretty pass via silly as I want that's
awesome so I start doing it and then
people started to kind of like the
comedy side so I fell in love with it
man it's the attention and love I've
always been looking for in sports that's
awesome and you were saying that yeah so
you've done a little stand-up in these
live shows yeah a bunch Stan tell us
about that Seattle going on yes yeah
well 900 people sold out show it's crazy
because all other shows get sold out if
Brian's like man what I think we should
do is we'll do a live show and I want
you to start with you going out first
doing stand-up that's brilliant but I've
never done Stan she's like don't worry
about it a good storyteller oh there
they go get straight till someone's
you're telling the story so I got right
so I just went out there telling the
stories and my first stand-up gig was
sold out theater in Seattle dude how
many people 900 900 people that's
horrifying now I'm just addicted to it
it's all I want to do I know it is a
great I will say like like performing is
a really fun feeling when it goes well
yes
yeah animus fight save his foot it's
like dude this is so easy this is real
it's not bad easy I know you like
stand-up there it's I love stand-up
because a lot like fighting because it's
pure like it's you and a mic and just
yeah I'm gonna make you like the same
it's the same as fighting either you're
winning or you're not Brian stand up
either you're making people laugh
nah yeah you know real quick if you're
funny yeah and you can't fake it no you
know I like money it's just like Nicki
either you gotta you got to just go for
it you gotta put your work in op dude
I'm I'm so fortunate because Joe Rogan
Chris D'Elia Bryan Callen go tonight
that's count those are my mentors man so
they help me out yeah those guys to him
at the top of their game for sure yes
it's so interesting to me like the Joe
Rogan thing is fascinating because you
know he was a stand-up forever and then
got in it's like this UFC MMA thing very
early on Gary
and now he's like one of like he's like
one of the main voice he's the guy the
thing about Joe is you know they try to
have all these shows now right they have
time to show all over the world and they
have other commentators but Joe brings
personality to it and he's an excellent
white so it's very hard to find and
Joe's thing is you know he grew up doing
Taekwondo he was national champion
Taekwondo guy yeah which is crazy cuz
I'm high I knew I was a stand-up he's a
black belt in jujitsu Jesus and then his
podcasts I mean you're talking about a
guy who gets 25 million downloads a
month like that's insane I guess in the
world that's crazy
his work ethic man you let's talk about
sony's inspiring really I've never seen
anything like it I really have to ask
them like how do you do it
just tell me how you do it that's insane
I love it it's insane man
and by the way to get tickets for for
any of the foyer of the kids live shows
go to TF 80k dot-com coming up I think
yeah you guys March April and May you
guys so coming up this month coming up
yeah in April we start with the Texas
tour then we end so we're in Houston
Dallas New Orleans Oklahoma oh my god
and then we end in Midwest with Chicago
Minneapolis and Wisconsin oh my god all
I'm hearing from you are great places to
eat foods at Albany I was just in Texas
oh my god barbecue dude your diet I'm
talking on the road look at you good in
LA I have an eating complex it's
freaking yes wait a sec can I go on the
road
this is actually good question like do
you now that you know fight anymore and
you don't do like you're not a
professional athlete anymore how how
hard is it to stay in shape are you just
kind of addicted to that light no I
think I'm addicted to kind of working
off I don't worked out I freaked out so
I still work out six or seven days a
week yeah before I came here I was doing
a pretty gnarly workout awesome but also
that there's nothing worse when you when
you see a guy who's been competing at a
high level and they seem a little
I'm basically the 12-step program yeah
on one tweety away from that turn to
Chris father yeah it's a struggle I
battle with it every day
I believe it yeah it was especially
being an entertainment Oh big anyways on
TV yeah Kasich worried about my figure
is funny when we were on tour with Conan
like back in 2009 and Mike Tyson we're
in Vegas Mike Tyson was on the celebrity
guys
I remember seeing I was like whoa man
like he got huge and now I think he's
he's got to be back he's back a little
bit here's the bummer though yeah two
minutes
bummer I get it because an athlete
all the time let's get back on the road
sweating like skinny jeans are like
tight clothes yeah yeah like yesterday
the everyone likes Easter right for the
religious Hall yes yes see I like today
because Cadbury eggs are half off there
we go that's the that's the real Easter
holidays no most Easter yeah I will go
straight here Lona we get a fashion you
said you had 250 pairs of shoes yeah no
I'm what you'd call a shoe now let's
talk about it what at this point now
because I probably have I'm a love shoes
and also watches too so I'm on this
ages you but like I maybe have like 30
pairs of shoes
what now attracts you to a shoe like
what are you cuz I feel like with
watches and shoes all go through phases
like I'm wearing these giant blue shoes
I love those yeah
Pumas Wade's got these I got I got the
adidas superstars you like bright yellow
likes and now I'm kind of more into like
a like a high-top face yeah I'm in the
high-top like Italian leather like yes
like for people listening I gather those
are expensive but there's coming great
brands out of yeah they're not a sponsor
okay they're similar to common projects
so common projects are my number one
shoe I'm obsessed with them wowing
leather basic shoe they look great with
jeans you wear them out to wear may not
been fraud coming projects but they're
really expensive well then great
spraying out of Brooklyn came about
they're very similar or they go great
great great straights alright great
they're very similar and you're talking
third of the price whoa
so now I I mean I just I don't know I
have a problem I don't see that's a
problem at all looking good how's that a
problem
crazy no I will say shoes are shoes are
kind of thing it's kind of like
furniture like you you pay for what you
get I use you know you look your feet
gotta be good to you buy a nicer buy it
twice I took that to the grave and I'm
just unfortunate in doing unfortunately
I'm a buy it nice and pet toys yeah but
that's doing problem I uh
if one pairs good two pairs better I uh
I just love shoes man I love everything
about him for my for my birthday the
number one she was trying to get I'm not
really into like Jordans and Nikes too
much anymore I kind of you know I go in
and out of that face yeah I'm for my
birthday my brother got me the the
easies baby this Oh what do you think
about the easies they're cool they're
you know I think it's more of you know
that they're so exclusive and they're
hard to get yeah so that's what makes
them really cool right right you know I
think it's just that kind of whole
appeal that Kanye made it's their myth
around you're buying like yeah you're
buying a doesn't have better shoes
Kozik well I'm just wearing a DS now I
warm on stage I'm like I kind of feel
like an [ __ ] Widow which easy which
easy come easy sigh got you the UH the
Lunars the Lunars oh yeah I guy I do
want to get a pair Easy's but that's the
thing too I feel the same way it's kind
of like uh oh jeez this guy is just
coming hard right now skies come the
super hot what's the Meher late that's
my Bailey boy what's my melee button X
I'm just thrilled right now but I'm also
happy I just got the moon rocks you
drank
yeah moon rocks there you go that's
rocking a pair easy yep what's your shoe
status I like where these shoes almost
every single thing that's like straight
out of like a Victorian novel no those
are those ones Doc Martin classic with
those bottoms those are not going
anywhere
yeah I think - well here's what now
people get on me about the fact I have
so many watches but as do man we can't
accessorize like the lady I agree you
know like winning ladies gosh your
name's your angel right well you can
wears a lot magician wears a watch if
you're a magician by the way I've
considered becoming a musician just like
an accessory a nutter all those rings I
feel like we could do pretty well as
magicians - put a little mascara you
know exactly you know like doing this a
lot like I feel like this is all have
you been to the Magic Castle yet no I
have not neither on man yeah nobody
Scientology probably it's but it's it's
supposed to be crazy because you watched
well first of all you have to dress up
oh really yeah it's like hippie suit
it's formal you have to worry now I want
to go yeah see there we go
I have to sweeten the pot also a little
bit is
people just walk around doing magic
maybe this doesn't sway the pot walk
around doing magic stuff and there's
drinking which is great and it's like
supposed to be good to eat good food and
stuff my friend unfortunately but they
take unfortunately they take it very
seriously so my friend got a little
drunk and couldn't remember like his
card he [ __ ] and [ __ ] up but then I
guess was also kind of a dick about the
whole thing and he got they kicked him
out
you got like band dude what kind of
security is at this magic place I'll
tell you I got a security you can't take
pictures either and this guy work with
ro he went and he tried to get a picture
with someone just against a wall and he
was like eight guards yeah we're just
like no I really want to go yeah exactly
[Applause]
how are you like I know my house Mel on
a date sir yes I am yeah absolutely
wait were you at hold on where you got
her like you can merked I think I wasn't
doing my job in catching up to you wait
all right that's the wrong guy okay
there we go there we go get up it's I
don't understand how I'm making you live
again I'm just literally helping you up
I'm not giving you like any pills or
anything I think you're like stabbing me
with
Kalin Kalin is a Taekwondo champion of
the great mr. Kim legacy what is that
so Kalin would always say early on
especially on you know we have a show
with Joe Rogan called the fight
companion podcast yeah where we watch
the UFC's and we commentate over it we
don't really talk about fighting we talk
about octopus and magic and whatever
cow's Tama how is a Taekwondo champ and
we were making fun of them here is he
really it's tougher debate there's no
pictures of mom and she's like it came
out Brian's like all right listen told
me in private just grown him over 800
right listen is that the YMCA there is
four people and I wanted okay and it was
in Iowa well that doesn't make you a
national champ right yeah what is this a
just stuck with it and then I was like
who's the master whoever who gave you
the black belt and he goes I think his
name is master Kim so we have
merchandise
so I created Bryan Callen Master Kim
national Taekwondo oh my job a this is
1983 but if you notice we have one
coming out this week the gate changes
every sure because it's a lie so every
day I change sweep the leg yes it's yes
Joe Rogan's a real national champ right
and he got national national tour oh my
god very suspect very suspect John yeah
he's really athletic done there we go
yeah for being 75 years old green 75 get
real kick your face yes sir out gets it
I'm pretty good Oh what an atomic tables
master Kim's shirt on right now yes
Wednesday black and gold new one we've
all seen Callen spin kick pretty legit
it is look I agree that's why it's hard
to debate oh he's got he's no no no Jay
it's on YouTube you like that's kind of
legit there's no there's just no proof
and he's a compulsive liar very tough
what are other things he lies about name
it and oh no Heyman
oh no it's brilliant to be his friend
though Johnny keep you on your toes
oh wait oh dang I feel like Phil right
in oh wow for shooting you in the
hey what are you at over here say what
you guys get out of the +4 coffee here
yeah oh there we go yeah that's the one
thing we live off of also obsessed with
toffee oh really
yeah I used to drink in between rounds
when I thought holy Moses
yeah man during sparring would you first
start drinking coffee like six or seven
nice man I'm a late comer to coffee
highly I never gonna do it until like
literally two years ago and now I'm just
the cold brew thing has changed my life
see I'm not a cold boot guy do you see I
if you're like cold Brews Rice's I only
drink iced coffee is that weird
you know what that's very odd American
yeah Seinfeld agree with me he's the
same where he doesn't agree with iced
coffee coffee should be caught up should
be hot man waits does but I don't drink
any other hot beverages you don't drink
tea uh I get but now I drink iced tea I
bet he's fine but see I came to it
through iced tea maybe that was my
gateway drug to it was iced kasam
vicious I need something a little a
little a little stronger than the iced
tea so I went iced coffee
there's some cold Brews that one I mean
it's like math I know I Stumptown it at
Whole Foods sometimes it's almost like a
Guinness yeah dude does not does not F
our own the only hot coffee but as a kid
my mom was born raised in England so I
grew up on that whopping Chianti look
not legit tea - tea with milk well every
night I still do it every night
peppermint tea and then I just slowly
transition to coffee that's great Oh
nerds if you're talking t-there's with
your best language oh yeah they're
watering into the Victorian novel yeah
well great like a peppermint tea Ria's
Julius we're hanging on the Brendan
Schaub the fighter in the kid podcast
and there's gonna be a live show so go
to TF ATK com2 grab your tix to see this
man live hopefully do youare you do do
stand
every time every time Wow awesome yeah
it's more it's more of a show than like
people because a lot of other podcasts
tried live podcasts it's just not the
platform and it's like boring to do a
podcast with just you know the guy
talking it doesn't come off that's true
as you would do it so you know Brian's a
performer and I like to perform myself
he goes no no no it's gonna be a perform
it's a show it's an actual show it's not
a podcast a show that's awesome and you
and you can you say that you guys are
doing actual a series also now we have a
series it just came out for pre-order
right now that it's tea fat k3d calm
yeah and what if you get it right now
for the pre-sale you get Brian towns
Comics special never grow up Wow
and you get a free find kid limb Edition
3d t-shirts oh my god that's awesome
then all twelve episodes drop me first
dude that's awesome I love that yeah
it's uh you know I've had some pretty
cool moments of my life and ethically
through football and fighting nothing
compares to knocking out these series I
believe investors cuz you know Mitch
rouse he's actually good buys Conan and
yeah has done a lot of riding and Brian
count myself we wrote these things and
to see it come to life I have never been
prouder of anything in my life it's like
it's like a child it's like because
you've you but you've created it and
then you send it out into the world for
other people doing do it we would meet
every Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday at
the pally house right here in Hollywood
and we'd go through ideas and all of us
would have to have 10 ideas Wow crazy no
to me you know obviously being an
athlete there's a lot of ego involved
right so when I come with my 10 ideas
and they go those are terrible
none of those won't work really hurt
your feelings so well you have to get
used to that rejection man but that's
that's how you do it it makes you
vulnerable on a whole other level you
know the creative process is so
interesting man I love it oh dude this
guy this guy's killing disguisting
gangster I'm all out of hammer - so what
are what are some if you're like comedic
influences like and and like in terms of
like you know shows you watch or people
you look up to yeah if you know but
besides the guys who kind of showed me
yeah besides the guys you personally
know yeah you know I'm a bit you dave
chappelle amazing amazing Tosh is really
good these days
I know I'm a big Seinfeld fan man yeah
dude the clap like the classics close up
also I my heroes growing up a lot of
people think it was athletes it was Adam
Sandler and Jim Carrey oh I believe it
anything they do I was I was game for me
yeah Ace Ventura came out I probably
missed Tuesday through Friday school ch
teacher over no and I came to school on
Monday oh my god you look ridiculous
I love it oh so somebody asked what is
what's actually better for more
satisfying like after a good fight or
after a good show good show because and
I've said this before because a fight
you know unless you're one of the you
know Conor McGregor Oh Jon Jones PD I'm
paying to see Jon Jones Conor McGregor I
was never that big of a superstar you
know how does it get fighter ranked in
the top ten for many years yeah the
thing is is they're coming to see
everyone at Rus shows the the love we
get any sold-out crowds they're coming
to see Bryan and Brendan yeah are after
arts we had a show in LA we sold out The
Comedy Store which is bad loss is crazy
do that so that's like the pinnacle
right ya know
historically yeah amazing - so after
that do die I went back to the green
room and I was in tears it was just for
me it's it's insane man because most
fighters when they get done fighting you
know there's not a lot to do you can
open a gym let's teach kids boxing like
there's not a lot of wit you know a
future there is tough unless you're at
the top it's very very tough even if you
have to top when you get done it's hard
to fill that void not for any athletes
just not fighting for sure and uh you
know I'm very grateful that for the UFC
they were great to me yeah and he's just
time for me to step away not another
option that you know to me I think was
kind of my desk absolutely yeah
and it's gonna be nice to I mean to get
out and especially someone like you has
such a great community to get out and
exercise that voice exercise that voice
I can be myself yeah silly run out I
just I just love it man and you know I
the shirts I'm super into fashion so
yeah that's awesome it's just the
perfect transition for me
luckily brain trauma hasn't set in yet
is all a dream I'm just actually in a
coma yeah this is alright we're all just
part of your dream right that's
hilarious dude would you ever want to
design your own like watch line and what
and what would it look like what would
it look like I don't know there's so
many watches out demanding I know you
have that you doubt that you'd have to
change you'd have to do something unique
I think dude I would love to design some
shoes I think I think these would eat it
up man especially was the right price
point toll stink and not athletic like a
nice Italian leather shoe there's a lot
of companies doing it a lot about it so
it's a difficult road to go down yeah
yeah collab with someone like grades or
come front or something I think that's
got to be the way to do it right because
otherwise like the production all that
stuff it's great like you have to almost
well kind of like how how can you get it
you know he didn't try to make his own
shoe company you know yes he's really
Yankee first and then they know how to
do they know how to do it best yeah he's
doing it right with that stuff man he
says lonely crazy stuff but as far as
fashion good right yeah that's pretty
legit I'd say save me to make it beats
he's still making good beats you know
yeah his new CD is pretty legit yeah
you're into that stuff I know that's the
thing although then again when you have
like a studio in Hawaii that you live in
I think it's pretty easy to be for sure
make more music yeah for sure yeah dude
when I was doing my research on you you
know I'm I still work out all the time
yeah and I was the number thing number
one thing with you and I'm sure all your
fans know but for the final kid fans did
you lost the tunnel layout after a girl
broke your heart 88 pounds yeah I've
been there man crazy that extreme but
when a girl breaks up with you it's
rushing these days on Instagram and
Twitter and you can see who they're
dating if you better stiff Akane it's
the work yeah it's literally it's the
best motivation in the world it really
is I mean yeah you want to you want to
get yourself to the gym just get into a
bad relationship and then it'll just be
like boom the pounds will melt away but
yeah that wasn't it experience cuz I
never been you know I
I'd never been into sports or anything
nothing great nothing no no that's up I
mean I'd play for fun with my friends
like pick up basketball and stuff but I
always been a really heavy guy and and
so it's kind of fun it was kind of fun
to me it's like kind of the opposite of
you like it was fun for me to use my
body and like I like it
hey I like it out there be like oh wow
like yes I'm different it gets strong it
out there yeah yeah like big guys like
us have a nice frame so it's cool to put
muscle on into you know when you're kind
of a big guy it's fun to get in the gym
and you know and work out because you
know diets the hard part diet are you
getting them the gyms easy right I kept
doing that the diet's the hard but yeah
that is the war can't be around sweets
yeah I'm like a gremlin man yeah as you
can't be around I turned in a demon for
me I remember the sweet thing was our
but salty man potato chips oh really oh
wow hate son oh man eat like I feel like
when my mom was breastfeeding me it was
just a natural syrup in her titty I'm
the worst she's seeing doctors soon
doctor pure maple syrup see a doctor get
with a sign with this pure maple syrup
it is true I will say like that is the
diet is is the worst part for sure by
far but but that's the thing too is like
I will say now with the internet there's
so many great resources out there where
you can like be like now like what
should I be eating or what's good I know
there's that it's hard to have an excuse
on what what you should eat you know
there's so much knowledge out there yeah
especially with podcast totally totally
yeah diet podcasts out there now workout
podcast back way yeah
wait so what do you you just said you
came for another workout water what are
you doing now what are you now I just I
do full body and Jitsu and mitts
usually every day oh wow yeah because I
used to do you know like wrestling high
quantity all all sorts of stuff man but
now I really just do stuff that look
good and feel good sure I guess turday I
knew that I was gonna have some sweets I
usually fast on
days last ball day on Sundays every
Sunday every Sunday Wow
but it was Easter so we're at a friend's
house and you know they're good food so
I woke up that morning and I ran six
miles Jesus I could get away with eating
like [ __ ] good lord that's awesome my
god yeah the UM I gotta say like it's
interesting like now that I've lost all
the weight trying to maintain it's a
whole different thing you know it's like
animal different animal it's a harder
animal for sure and do you have a
girlfriend now
no no no no yeah you became a ladies man
Yeah right
just kill them again kill another Caprio
now here's a great here's actually a
funny starting off Friday night are you
ready for a great story here we go so uh
you know because I'm a winner I was at
the bookstore on Friday night Noble but
now this get asked I like books on I'm
like Vermont's over there and I just
come from the comic book store side a
bunch of comic books and left left path
of right path let's go left left alright
um so let's just go over your Friday
night real Friday so a book store down
like story book story that's everyone's
ex yeah just beating them up and there's
cute girl behind the counter right work
in that comic book store at the regular
books okay yeah and you know girls will
now flirt with me I mean girls obviously
flirt with you all the time but girls
it's a weird new thing for me so um and
she's behind the counter and so I was
like oh hey like could i donate like you
know like a dollar to this children's
thing and I wasn't doing this Yeah right
cause it is the girl hey you like kid
knows it yeah yeah you know I can donate
it so she goes she's like oh my god she
goes oh my god that's so sweet and
reaches across the thing kind of like oh
that's so sweet and I was like Ross if
it's all yeah so what I say is well
we've all got a child inside of us she's
like what oh no I was like oh you're
still learning and that's why I go well
then I'm sorry I kind of panicked and so
then I was kind of like oh I mean I eat
children uh have a good day she's like
what and I'm starting to actually sweat
now what I'm telling
yeah it was terrible and and so and I
was looking at she's like huh and then I
go because I mechanical and then she
goes well then she tries help me she
goes wow you're going pretty far she's
like you're really sticking to his riff
huh and I was like yep
yeah and at this point like I'm trying
to swipe my car just desperately
together and it keeps me I keep doing it
too fast it's like beep beep but she has
to keep resetting it it's terrible and
that's so she's like oh and I was like
yeah well they'll taste like chicken
everybody and I was like sometimes I'll
uh she's like yeah oh geez seasoning I'm
like yeah yeah I use seasoning sometimes
and uh and it whatever and I'm just like
screaming at this point I don't know I
was saying and that's so she's like
quiet I swiped my thing she think she's
like okay well I'm gonna I'm like thanks
and then I'm leaving as I'm leaving
Sheila gives me one more chance to peek
to like be normal and she's like well
hope to see you in here again soon and I
go call the authorities the only way
that could have went any worse she's
like hey how you doing good and brought
out a do you like books literally the
words so I'm still getting used to at
the six of ya say the least say the
least
oh it's the worst what you're late now
what's your situation uh I have a
girlfriend awesome have a girlfriend and
you know in LA and I'm on the road all
the time yeah yeah yeah it's tough but
although I will say with Skype it's
tough it feels easier than it would be
like you know eight or ten years ago
well what's tough is you know there's
more access to people these days yeah
Instagram Twitter all that stuff anyone
can access any one they want that's true
anyone so absolutely the struggle is
real the struggle is real man struggle
is real it's tough and I will say - like
it's interesting like out here in LA
it's it's it's interesting because in
new you are ice live in New York and
meeting people is so easy because
everyone's drunk all the time and you
walk anywhere yeah yeah that's fine so
so easy peasy right but here when people
drive to bars
then it's like okay you get let's say
you get a girl to go home and now we'd
both driven to the bar who's following
who are we take is someone leaving the
car here like what's happening like and
then if you do if she's like yeah I'll
follow you then it's like oh and if she
doesn't make it through a yellow light
it's like Oh like did she mean to just
it's terrible the hoping the issue is is
I think the problem there is you're
trying to meet girls at bars all right
you guys need to do you know step
outside their Lane like yoga yoga or
salsa there we go what club yeah there's
like Saturday morning workout regimen on
them you talk about eating children at a
bookstore that's like that might that
might work too yeah
oh you know what if she had actually
maybe admit that could have been it
could've been funny that have been fun
it could have played the game right she
could have you know what she could have
helped me out she really could um she
could see how he's drowning you know
what when I started swiping the thing 15
times in a row yeah I better help shake
it a bit like Yee oh my god she wasn't
doing anything no definitely not but you
know what I will say that Children's
Hospital got a a really big dog kept
swiping pain they probably got like $600
at least here we go where um I think
you're good bye yeah you're about to
join me over here well also I figured
out the chainsaw thing if you hold down
beating oh really I think yeah yeah I
think you can cut Deutz in half which is
fun so are you by the guy who's shooting
uh fun fact if a girl looks at you it
means she's DTF yeah I don't know about
yeah that's aggressive that's a girl
really aggressive hostile salt brother
pretty good you know no one mentions
ballet you know I would take ballet I've
taken ballet yeah I feel like cuz it
makes you more graceful you know like
yeah I don't know if that's the right
setting I think you're better off with a
little yoga or salsa dancing to the
salsa now are you a salsa dancer you
didn't salsa day that's a lot Stan
tomalak every Wednesday I feel like
salsa is kind of like it's cuz it's
already it's kind of you know you're
moving your body you're working up a
sweat it's obsession you know exactly I
got I don't know about these hips though
man like that's why you need to go bro
like look I think I need like this is
not is this how you saw sit back I'm al
at it okay
Wow are you gonna marry another stars
very clean that probably not would you
do Dancing with the Stars yeah sure
that'd be awesome yeah it would be fun
although I don't it seems like that
seems pretty soon like a real word come
yeah I'm like a real beast
yeah that's your fun and that dance is
not easy it's true
salsa dances are none I know I feel like
having to do all the different styles
and stuff and then perform in front of
people seems horrible and not only not
advanced within the other all right
exactly
is there anything I mean you have you've
been in the ring you fought people you
don't stand up in front of hundreds of
people is there anything that scares you
is there any like is there anything now
that's scary
like for sure like what like skydiving
like what is it you know I'm uh what's
left I would never stop I would never
skydive it's tough to get me out of LA
besides doing these live tours you're
scared of every place except for LA
basically like Isis is every original
terrorism Plus yeah because there we go
yeah danger town yeah unless you got
good food in your town you don't want to
travel if you have good food on there
you have good doughnuts if you if you
open up with doughnuts doughnuts way we
start with don't do doughnut technology
from when we were kids has gone bananas
all we had was Dunkin Donuts man now
it's a guy sells at Dunkin Donuts it
tastes like card no there's blue star
fabok any yeah who do doughnuts that
will change your life is that the one
there's there's these doughnuts I've
seen done this with like see like Lucky
Charms and donut that is insane you know
what out a blue stars out candy they
have some nerve man I'm not mix up I got
a dozen donuts how much would you pay
for a dozen donuts eight bucks yeah try
56 Oh what how dear American dollars not
talking about we're not talking paces
some nerve man oh look at it
that strugglers oh my god so it said
shamrocks red shake shop your favorite
no no shame but shake is uh
poison what yeah it's a shamrock shake
from McDonald's I never go to McDonald's
yeah but I tried to shamrock shake
because I think Keely and from fine kid
and Evan the beard didn't shut up about
it okay so it was like I think there's
last year Saint patty you never had a
shamrock shake never how is that
possible
misty you just skated through like if I
want something sweet I'm sure tell not
gonna McDonald that's true that's a
great one great point yeah so I finally
got one and it was just I could feel my
insides are you a shake guy though are
you a shake guy you like [ __ ] okay if
it's good quality ingredients yeah I you
know what any any time they give you the
the metal cup with a spoon I'm in I'm in
house of pies you been to house of pies
I've been uh I most feel this great [ __ ]
cupcake guy - Oh cup oh my god don't get
me started
I for my birthday was 18th March 18 yeah
and you know I've been good not even
sugar and yeah agent Adam Hirsch sent me
a dozen of these Susie's cupcakes in LA
are they the ones that are just like
you've towards they're not that big with
the frostings like like your mom used to
make you Oh buttercream dude I you know
it's my birthday I'm just go one so I
had one and then at night I couldn't
sleep without starving for my dad yeah
so I'm like how can I do this so you
know I decided was the best way to go I
ate the top and then swim away that's
like a true cupcake package understand
I'm just gonna do this did you do you
did you after a fight did you use to uh
did you used to like treat yourself to
cupcakes or anything like really you
know I'll get don't find like I can't
wait for this I really never drink
either yeah I'm like man after this
fight or after this big show or after we
finish this fine the kid 3d series yeah
so much fun if I get it done I'm like I
just don't want to do anything yeah I
just wanna relax and I don't I guess
have
I guess I'm getting older oh there we go
or more classy or more classy you're
right
you know nothing nothing wrong with the
class little bit yeah why why does
something I wish I knew more about
that's why that's why having a best
friend who's 50 and he's a wine
connoisseur Oh see my account man he
makes me look good that's order wine I'm
just like make sure you order two
because it's like I think like get like
can you cook
I can cook yeah see that's the thing is
like wine and cooking like there's a
point at which I've said this before but
like as guys like it's when you're
younger it's kind of cute like oh we
can't cook oh he doesn't know but as you
get older it's not cute like you got it
like you gotta change the lightbulb
attire yeah yeah I don't know how to
grill yeah a man's man I feel like that
it's becoming more and more there's a
little more demand there like you got a
no magic I'd be more like a Swiss Army
knife less like a machete yeah no I
could own a meat head know that don't be
mean
well played yeah yeah look more like a
Swiss Army ed let's look at machete
because yeah it's just like and wine is
one of those things I feel like it's
cool it's it's cool to know about what's
very cool yeah like that's the thing I'm
trying to learn more about tequila dude
books to book oh my god I suppose he got
you know in college I majored in
football as a double major but when he
played Division one football you're
basically majoring foot boy so you know
I I didn't read a ton I read certain
books on professional athletes and
working out yeah I was in two and now
it's like especially the group I hang
out with man being big fast and strong
it's really not that cool like being a
meathead those days are over me over me
it's about neoneun I know it sounds
cliche but knowledge is power especially
with girls
absolutely it's not gonna get you very
far anymore man agreed yeah I mean those
days are over man the 90s are done my
knees are done we learned different
things about tequila every day that's
right like how it can make you hurt yeah
if you drink too much of it it's good
point
that's right oh my god ammos I'm getting
destroyed thanks I'm gonna kill us down
we'll come get you all right here we go
I like that I like it I need oh these
laughs like that what
[Music]
well I think I'm doubt I think I'm down
on the writer guy on my team or no I
think yeah I think he's who I'm about to
do hey man
cooking is the best elementary school to
know agree the great Shabet UFC 200 yeah
right yeah yes it is Brendan Schaub if
you don't make me wear Reebok and let me
find a superstorm in somebody said
dragons are real oh yeah because I make
fun of movement coaches and Dragons okay
someone's trying to get me watch games
of throne okay that's it
Oh is there dragon what yelling good
party years old I'm all set so then you
know dude I grown man write me emails
like how do you drag ins are real
they're not no they're just not one of
my favorite things about Game of Thrones
is so the author that guy george RR
martin he always like this tiny little
dude he's exactly a guy if you look at
him you should have picture him read
he's kind of yeah small yeah
he looks like he's written those novels
my favorite thing is he's from new
jersey is that the greatest thing like
you expect him to be in like Finland
Zulu Jersey bro like vibe yeah sméagol
by basement dragon yeah yeah before
george RR martin is from jersey i love
it just like walking around new jersey
picking like dragons and all this crazy
really he's brilliant yeah I heard this
awesome thing where if you if you what
is it if you recognize him on the street
if you run into him on the street he
carries around these little coins gold
coins that said like I met George are
Martin look at that awesome
it's just it's a very yeah that's very
ego yeah I'm pretty enjoyed there yeah
he's like Scrooge McDuck he just gives
out gold yeah I mean there's a lot of
girl do you get about it work I mean I
gotta say I will say like he's clearly
made a lot of money
Oh gave a thought he's killing killing
it I bet you want type of guy who
doesn't struggle with the lady but you
walk in his room is just dragging it all
of it I love it if that you can you
Jersey industrial waste that's that's
actually there are probably dragons in
Jersey sorry Jersey it's a good chance
so drop some iguanas yep
in that River there exactly exactly
all right I think actually I think
that's gonna do it it's one o'clock
everybody thank you to Vernetta thank
you for the best man that's right and
please again go buy tickets at a TFA TK
or T fat K yeah I'm calm calm that's
right and check the fighter in the kid
on iTunes SoundCloud everywhere a great
podcast can be seen I bread shop
everybody thank you so my guys you guys
do is run in melee thank you we'll see
you guys next week see you later
you